[Music]
our neighbors canada
why no chill over there guys now
trials decriminalizing cocaine mdma and
other drugs you know what i didn't like
canada at first they'd be in the article
now
they decriminalized cocaine they have
announced that they will temporarily
decriminalize the possession of small
amounts of some illicit drugs in british
columbia
the province asked for the criminal code
exemption after overdoses claimed more
than 2 000 lives in the british columbia
last year
this time limited three-year trial is
the first of its kind in canada and
adults will be allowed to possess a
combined total of 2.5 grams
of opioids cocaine methamphetamine and
mdma interesting is that like 2.5 grams
like physically that's not it's like a
little i don't know
i'm just making shapes in my hands
that's like a like 2.8 grams is not that
much at all it's probably like probably
like that yeah how much protein powder a
handful of pills yeah okay probably like
this much that's more
that's a lot do you move it here oh
yeah is the whole reason for
decriminalizing it like that is that to
they think that's going to prevent
overdoses this is too really big they're
probably dragging these games
but the end game goal is so that less
people overdose no it's too it's to
punish dealers but not the users
okay that's when people say
decriminalize it they're talking about
decriminalizing the usage right the
casual users because they're pinning
like the people that are just
recreational users so they're trying to
make the dealers like
to make dealing even more illegal
well in situations like this like if it
were to happen for example in america
then like all those black people that
like were in possession of like this
much weed that have like life sentences
that should never happen you know what i
mean because they're not the dealers
they just maybe had a small amount yeah
you know what i'm saying so anything in
the combined total of 2.5 grams like
chances are you aren't the dealer you're
not the huge issue on the street that
makes sense
yeah and there's also like different
rules too like um if you had weed back
in the day or just any kind of drugs and
then if you were if you had them in
individual bags
like like like you had them separated
that's already intent to sell
wow yeah oh so this is mainly to like
refocus resources for well also also it
says while those substances will remain
illegal adults found possession for
personal use will not be arrested
charged or have the drug seized yeah see
instead they will be offered information
on available health and social services
in exchange for information on where you
actually
it happens already yeah
there's a lot of countries already that
does that like i think in like
one of those good rehabilitation
countries like sweden or whatever like
they act they have [ __ ] drug dens
that are government funded and you could
go in and [ __ ] and use their needles and
everything clean and then they have
kiosks that you can go [ __ ] trip at
that's crazy don't we have that here
issue like under wraps
no but they have a place where you could
just go in and then like they just do it
can't you do that at the needle exchange
can you go there and play world of
warcraft you should be yeah
yeah because that's like a whole thing
right
that's where you go do drugs in games
okay oh that's a good comment drug game
addiction yeah gamer addiction is a
whole thing yeah so imagine having a
government regulated place where it's
like you can come and fight play
warcraft but it's safe we don't keep
mountain dews here yeah
exactly
in its request of the federal government
last year british columbia said it asked
for the drug laws exemption in order
quote to remove the shame that often
prevents people from reaching out it's
for the shame that's stupid
that's all that's the only reason it's
really stupid
federal minister of mental health and
addictions said on tuesday that quote
for too many years the ideological
opposition to harm reduction has cost
lives we are doing this to save lives
but also to give people using drugs
their dignity and choices
here's a hot take do we really need to
can we have a little more shame in the
world because i think uh more shame i
think the last generation of asians did
a good job on putting so much shame on
us that it helped us not [ __ ] up
honestly
the threat of shame
was unbeatable yeah in raising us no it
was beatable
it was a pretty legit thing i mean now
it's like a dumb kung fu it can't be all
[ __ ] up though didn't we all bring
shame to our family in one way or
another but i think it's tons of shame
oh it adjusted the threshold where like
some stuff was too shameful that like
you know i never murdered anyone because
of the shame
[Laughter]
hot take i like some uh stories of
countries tyrant dictator presidents
that like duarte completely [ __ ]
behead like drug dealers and [ __ ] like
that and go over the top to set examples
in order to like you know minimize the
uh the crime rate yeah it's like does
north korea have a drug problem no they
just enslave their citizens to make meth
and sell it overseas exactly and you
know there's
something progressive about the
of not getting high on your own supply
mm-hmm
they don't get their own
stick stick with that the whole video
because my favorite things about you
know it's like um it's like well iran
doesn't have a pride month
and it's like that's who really needs a
pride month yeah yeah okay and it's like
you remember a minute i'm a dinosaur
he's like there's no gay people here
so in that 2020 uh
interview he was like what do you mean
we don't have gay people you're
crazy he's like they just don't they
don't exist here actually it's like it
has nothing to do with suppression so
they don't exist yeah not in our country
are you crazy the best i don't know what
you guys are doing in your country my
country we don't got no games no we
don't got that stuff here we don't have
a word for it
i don't even know what you said
i'm gonna do the job
the americans want to suck each other
off all day but we don't have that in
iran
i mean you're a little [ __ ] country
yeah we [ __ ] dig
yep
we're busy rapping there's no room for
gays with that much prayer going on
so stupid
so they say uh british columbia declared
the overdose crisis a public health
emergency five years ago and overdose
deaths have since reached historic highs
in the shadow of the covid19 pandemic
over 9 000 people have died of drug
overdose in the province since 2016.
there have been growing calls for a
shift in drug policy towards a public
health approach from regions across the
country
that has included support for some
decriminalization from a number of
public health officials as well as the
canadian association of chief police
and in in terms of just like templates
and how this kind of works in 2020
oregon became the first u.s state to
drop criminal penalties for the
possession of some illicit drugs the
state saw a drop in drug arrest though
there were there's been some debate as
to whether it's prompted more drug users
to seek help for their substance use i
hate that i also hate that correlation
when they go hey we stopped making drugs
illegal there have been less drug
arrests no [ __ ] it's it's not illegal
anymore
i love that you're not gonna arrest
people
why do they do that they always do that
when i read that i'm like that's good
news that's like what's happening in
that's like what's what's happening in
l.a right it's like they're like hey
guys crime is down and it's like no it's
not there's more [ __ ] break-ins
there's more there's like a restaurant
there's [ __ ] there yeah there's
arrests happening you're just not
prosecuting you're just not prosecuting
yeah like crime is down on christmas
because it's christmas yeah because it's
christmas guys or it's like what was
that last announcement they made where
um someone was like some official from
the white house was like the economy's
actually never been better
based on that [ __ ] ass that was the
best oh did you see the congresswoman uh
our senator whatever the [ __ ] who gives
a [ __ ]
um my favorite senator like she was like
she's like you know what it was great i
was driving in my electric vehicle and i
passed all these gas stations where i
guess there's it's expensive but that
wasn't a problem at all so we just need
to really move towards that it's like
dude hey [ __ ] you hey nick go buy a
[ __ ] tesla you stupid piece of [ __ ]
stop complaining about gas prices you
poor idiot yeah what's wrong with you
seven dollars a gallon get a new car
that's it jackass dude we should go dude
if i was still trolling i would go to
the gas station right now with a mega
phone and just yell at people for not
buying a [ __ ] tesla
now there's people actually that sounds
like a good steve green company
there's is a funny thing but like i
recently uh met these people that uh
they're expanding their business to la
but i guess it exists in texas already
it's it's uber but it's all electric
vehicles so if you're like very uh like
if you're more uh nature conscious like
or you're vegan you don't want to ride
in an uber that's running on gas
and leather seats but they already offer
that on uber here uber or lyft like you
have a choice to choose but that's like
eating a vegan burger at burger king
it's like it'll still make you upset
yeah because like you're like that's the
same grill where they cook them dude
imagine being a vegan but not taking an
uber because like it's a gas vehicle it
has leather seats and why because of the
shame thank you
nobody can you order barbecue for this i
found it was interesting because uh
this company like oh it's mostly teslas
and i'm like
how many people who could afford a tesla
are going to want to be an uber driver
that's so true there's there's a number
of tesla uber drivers but isn't there
like a uber luxury where well because
one the tesla 3 is supposed to be like
technically affordable there's actually
more vehicles out there that cost more
than tesla three that are actually uber
cars for example oh yeah uber black i
can't afford that [ __ ]
uber black cheaper starting baseball
less than 35 000
yeah a tesla model three if you don't
get all the extra [ __ ] bells and
whistles why do you want all the [ __ ]
you want this
auto drive yeah you want the car to
dance so imagine imagine you get low
grade tesla model three and you're not
paying for gas when you gotta like uber
people around that's true you know what
i mean like that must be a little bit
more of a payday but then it costs
twelve thousand dollars i really use
coal to get elected
don't say that man you're gonna ruin
that dream like that's not the point i
think the idea 50 [ __ ] percent dude
like it's like 70. that's right
it's like you're gonna use the coal
anyway are you using it to build the
coal comes from the earth it's okay yeah
this conversation you're a dancer just
[Laughter]
hey dance the funny moves dancer
come on do it let's dance this guy's
wife wins one world series of poker so
he's talking real [ __ ] out here let's go
[ __ ] let's fight right now you
wanna [ __ ] fight finally let's
finally [ __ ] end this take off the
[ __ ] colts drizzy
[Music]
fight
[Music]